Israeli air strikes are blamed for this
major destruction in a residential
neighborhood in a Frontline Village in
Lebanon its biggest bombardment in the
10we conflict along the
border much of the area is empty as tens
of thousands of people have fled the
daily exchanges between Hezbollah and
the Israeli Army prompted by the war on
Gaza recently Israel's strikes have
intensified and the Lebanese armed group
is using more powerful weapons in its
attacks on Israeli military outposts and
Soldiers the United Nations peacekeeping
mission is raising the
alarm as I said over the weekend there
has been a large number of of shelling
also one of our uh base was it the
Watchtower in one of the Spanish
compound likely no injuries uh but of
course uh the longer this conflict
continues and uh there is an increase in
the possibility of a of a wider
conflict despite the frequent exchanges
which have led to casualties on both
sides the violence is largely limited to
the Border area but Israel is warning of
a wider conflict if Hezbollah doesn't
withdraw in a show of force Israeli
warplanes fly over the Lebanese Capital
Beirut the Israeli military says if
Hezbollah doesn't respond to diplomacy
it will have to impose a new reality to
make Israelis feel safe to return to
their homes in the North I don't think
Israel is ready at the moment to uh
confront a new uh front that can really
expose its weaknesses and uh jeopardize
the security of all the cities in Israel
Hezbollah is a stronger Force than Hamas
in Gaza but so far it has been
calibrating attacks to prevent a
full-blown
conflict the United States and France
are trying to avoid a military
escalation sending envoys to Beirut to
try to reach a diplomatic solution early
in the war the US sent military assets
to the region to deter Iran and its Ally
Hezbollah from attacking Israel but now
many fear Israel May widen the
confrontation Israeli media are
reporting a possible deadline to reach a
settlement with
Hezbollah there's a lot of uncertainty
but what is clear is that Hezbollah
won't back down until Israel's war on
Gaza ends and all the while tension is
mounting on this front Zak alaz
Beirut make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz